Caption: who here is a fan of superhero movies
Caption: i'd imagine pretty much everyone that
Caption: looks at it
Caption: they be ubiquitous nowadays i'm pretty
Caption: sure i saw the new black widow movie by
Caption: accident
Caption: personally one of my favorite heroes is
Caption: superman
Caption: he's faster than a speedy bullet more
Caption: powerful than a locomotive you can drop
Caption: two buildings in a single bound
Caption: but if you expose him to a green rock he
Caption: crumbles
Caption: anyone can defeat superman if you just
Caption: have a piece of kryptonite and this is
Caption: why i love about him
Caption: he has these extreme strengths seemingly
Caption: a god with limited powers
Caption: but he has this extreme weakness that
Caption: reduces them to nothing as these
Caption: extremes which is such a great
Caption: uh analogy for neurodiversity
Caption: because neurodiversity is about extremes
Caption: as you can see on the screen the rainbow
Caption: line represents neurons people and it
Caption: bounces between very high and very low
Caption: for various cognitive skills
Caption: a cognitive skill is a little bit
Caption: different to a regular skill a regular
Caption: skill is stuff like how good you are at
Caption: java or jump script or how you can
Caption: design a database or
Caption: how good you are web design or how about
Caption: uh designing a decision tree
Caption: where a cognitive skill is the skills
Caption: that underline and empower those
Caption: stuff like your organizational ability
Caption: uh however you can organize your day and
Caption: your calendar your innovation skills how
Caption: well you can come up with new and
Caption: creative ideas your executive
Caption: functioning skills which is taking a big
Caption: idea and break up into lots of little
Caption: ideas
Caption: your design skills your time management
Caption: skills your empathy your focus
Caption: and your socializing skills people with
Caption: neurodiversity have extreme strengths
Caption: and extreme weaknesses in these areas
Caption: where and it differs by different
Caption: neurodiverse individuals for me i'm very
Caption: good at organizing innovation
Caption: executive functioning skills but i can
Caption: struggle with time management sometimes
Caption: when i get a bit too focused into what
Caption: i'm doing and miss a meeting
Caption: someone who's neurotypical still has
Caption: these strengths and weaknesses but
Caption: they're less extreme
Caption: so if you can often think about
Caption: neurodiverse people as people who are
Caption: specialized in cognitive skills
Caption: and these cognitive skills empower their
Caption: regular skills and
Caption: teams already have specialists
Caption: you have the customer whisperer who's
Caption: capable of after you spend two hours
Caption: explaining to the customer why what they
Caption: want is a bad idea
Caption: he comes in spends five minutes with the
Caption: customer and the customer tells him it's
Caption: a bad idea
Caption: you have the sql ninja
Caption: who can write a query that runs ten
Caption: times faster than the one you wrote
Caption: because she deeply understands the
Caption: underlying database you have the linux
Caption: legend who can simply make linux do
Caption: literally anything i'm pretty sure he
Caption: might make him a cup of coffee the other
Caption: day
Caption: the jira expert who
Caption: spent does the laborious work of cnn
Caption: jira so we can all enjoy it
Caption: and then you have perhaps the most
Caption: important skill willing to write cobalt
Caption: of the guy who understands regex the
Caption: cloud guru and or the genius debugger
Caption: someone who's neuroverse just fits
Caption: in as a cognitive specialist in in
Caption: addition to being a regular specialist
Caption: and that's how teams work we all have
Caption: our strengths our weaknesses and it
Caption: makes us fit better together but let's
Caption: take a step back
Caption: and talk about what is neurodiversity
Caption: well what does the dictionary say
Caption: the range of differences in individual
Caption: brain function and painful traits rug
Caption: out as a part of normal variation in the
Caption: human population
Caption: well
Caption: that's quite obtuse as you'd expect from
Caption: oxford dictionary but let's break it
Caption: down a little bit
Caption: it's basically saying that people who
Caption: are nervous have brains that function
Caption: differently
Caption: and because of that they have this can
Caption: impact their behavior in various ways
Caption: basically people are nervous have minds
Caption: of different kinds
Caption: and that these differences are regarded
Caption: as normal seen often in the human
Caption: population
Caption: but whenever something has a normal
Caption: variation
Caption: scientists big scientists like to put
Caption: names on it so let's look to talk about
Caption: stories in our very normal variations
Caption: these are six of the common
Caption: neurodiverse conditions
Caption: you have dyspraxia
Caption: which should be with strong and verbal
Caption: skills empathy and intuition
Caption: and when i talk about these conditions
Caption: typically when we talk about uh
Caption: neurodiverse conditions we talk about
Caption: what they struggle with and what their
Caption: weaknesses are and that's important
Caption: things to be aware of but today we've
Caption: going to talk about the strengths
Caption: yield is calculator which are people
Caption: with strong verbal skills and innovative
Caption: thinking
Caption: you have tourette syndrome people with
Caption: strong observational skills confident
Caption: control and creativity you have autism
Caption: spectrum condition which people with
Caption: strong concentration five detailed
Caption: processing and memory you have dyslexia
Caption: it will be strong visual thinking
Caption: creative skills and 3d mechanical skills
Caption: and despite what you may think 3d
Caption: mechanical skills do come up with
Caption: software development
Caption: adhd which is people with creativity
Caption: hyper focus energy and passion
Caption: i actually was fortunate to work with a
Caption: great colleague who had adhd and she
Caption: said to me
Caption: ryan my superpower is
Caption: no matter what time of day it is
Caption: i can go full speed like my energy and
Caption: passion no matter what time it is
Caption: motivates the rest of the team even if
Caption: it's 4 p.m on a friday night or if it's
Caption: like 2 a.m because something went wrong
Caption: and that really shows the strengths of
Caption: nervous people let's talk about
Caption: prevalence
Caption: around 17 ish percent of people have had
Caption: uh have neurodiversity four percent with
Caption: adhd one percent with autism ten percent
Caption: dyslexia one percent dyspraxia and one
Caption: percent tourettes
Caption: now there are two problems with these
Caption: statistics the first of all is it varies
Caption: by population
Caption: so our industry the software industry
Caption: tends to have a higher rate of
Caption: neurodiversity especially autism
Caption: where
Caption: and the second problem is
Caption: this is the universe is what's known as
Caption: a tip of the iceberg problem
Caption: there is the visible portion and that's
Caption: the portion of people who are diagnosed
Caption: and disclosed that they're diagnosed a
Caption: lot of people choose not to the other
Caption: problem being is to get diagnosed you
Caption: have to appear in father psychologists
Caption: at some point in your life
Caption: if things go well if your new diversity
Caption: maps onto society well that may never
Caption: happen so you can go your whole life not
Caption: knowing about it
Caption: and that's that's perfectly fine if
Caption: you're a happy person
Caption: there's one more thing to think about
Caption: when it comes to talking about what
Caption: neurodiversity is
Caption: and that's
Caption: what neurodiversity is to people who are
Caption: neurodiverse
Caption: the most important idea to understand
Caption: here is different does not equal
Caption: disabled
Caption: so
Caption: nervous people think as i said of
Caption: themselves people with minds of
Caption: different kinds
Caption: minds that have different strengths and
Caption: weaknesses
Caption: and different quirks than the
Caption: neurotypical person
Caption: often
Caption: uh we see just the struggles but
Caption: that's because
Caption: they do come insurance
Caption: but the relationship between
Caption: neurodiversity and disability is complex
Caption: some people who are neurodiverse are
Caption: disabled some are not
Caption: and the relationship is far out of scope
Caption: for this talk
Caption: but that's something to keep in mind and
Caption: there's a really good analogy to explain
Caption: this
Caption: let's say
Caption: you've had an amazing day at work
Caption: you somehow nailed four features and
Caption: deployed them in a single day
Caption: you design showed the client your
Caption: website design and he loved it
Caption: you
Caption: made a model and it has 99.99 accuracy
Caption: and you're just feeling amazing at the
Caption: data it's new levels of productivity you
Caption: don't even know how you do it then at
Caption: the end of the day
Caption: you go home and do whatever you enjoy
Caption: for many people here that'd be video
Caption: games
Caption: for others you might watch tv read a
Caption: book go to the gym walk the dog whatever
Caption: it is for you and you go to bed at the
Caption: end of the day and you're like i wish
Caption: every day could be like this
Caption: then you wake up the next morning get
Caption: groggy have your cup of coffee
Caption: and
Caption: you read the news
Caption: and to your absolute shock
Caption: everybody but you
Caption: spawned beautiful angel wings overnight
Caption: and you're like oh gosh i feel so
Caption: unlucky
Caption: and you see them you know flying about
Caption: flying soccer was invented overnight
Caption: and you're like oh well that sucks which
Caption: i why did i have to be the one who runs
Caption: out who missed out but
Caption: you carry on with your life you have
Caption: work to do
Caption: deadlines to meet
Caption: and over time you start to wonder
Caption: yourself am i disabled because everyone
Caption: else can do this thing i can't do
Caption: the nervous community and the disability
Caption: community would argue no
Caption: because you can still do
Caption: everything you need to have a fulfilling
Caption: life you can still work you can still
Caption: make your own meals you can still go to
Caption: social events you know when you go to
Caption: work you catch the bus they have to
Caption: rename trans perf to trans you because
Caption: the only person who needs it now
Caption: and more or less your life goes on but
Caption: then one day
Caption: some newfangled head comes along and
Caption: goes well
Caption: everybody can fly now so i'm gonna build
Caption: a building for flying people he puts a
Caption: big long cylinder at the middle so you
Caption: can fly to the level you live on or want
Caption: to visit he puts a big helipad on the
Caption: top so everyone can land a nice solid
Caption: ground
Caption: and it's at this point
Caption: that you've become a disabled person
Caption: because if you want to visit someone in
Caption: that tower or if you want to have a
Caption: meeting in that tower you can't
Caption: and this is where different doesn't
Caption: equal disabled comes back in the reason
Caption: why neurodiverse people struggle so much
Caption: is they live in a society that wasn't
Caption: designed for them
Caption: a someone with autism once quipped that
Caption: to someone with autism society seems one
Caption: that's disorganized chaotic and obsessed
Caption: with socializing in physical contact
Caption: and i'm sure in your other neural
Caption: conditions
Caption: neurodiversity would have similar points
Caption: and this really is why allyship is so
Caption: important
Caption: there's a artwork from the lgbt
Caption: community that i really like which is on
Caption: the slide right now
Caption: and explains why ally is a verb not a
Caption: noun
Caption: being an ally doesn't mean
Caption: saying that you're alive being an ally
Caption: doesn't mean
Caption: bragging about it or putting into a row
Caption: it means doing things
Caption: so let's talk about what you can do
Caption: so the first thing you can do is
Caption: understand disclosure
Caption: some people
Caption: uh might go their entire life being
Caption: neurodiverse and they know it and they
Caption: just don't want to tell you because it's
Caption: a private health matter i don't expect
Caption: you to tell me all your health matters
Caption: and why should expect me to tell yours
Caption: and they can adapt while in the
Caption: workplace because the way their
Caption: neurodiversity manifests maps well onto
Caption: society and that's perfectly okay
Caption: for other people however it's a serious
Caption: dilemma
Caption: because they have to choose between
Caption: disclosing and risking stigma because
Caption: there's a lot of negative stereotypes
Caption: around neurodiverse people from people
Caption: with autism being unfriendly and
Caption: disliking people to people with adhd
Caption: being annoying and never getting work
Caption: done
Caption: and then they're worried that if they
Caption: disclose they'll get a lot of stigma
Caption: from it
Caption: no matter what neurodiverse condition
Caption: you have
Caption: it's when you disclose it it's basically
Caption: admitting that you have a weakness
Caption: on the other hand if they don't disclose
Caption: then they struggle in science there are
Caption: key changes that can be made to their
Caption: job and their environment to get more
Caption: performance and to get more quality of
Caption: life out that they don't but they can't
Caption: because they're so afraid
Caption: and
Caption: if someone discloses to you
Caption: make sure to validate it make sure they
Caption: feel accepted and then ask how you can
Caption: make things better or if you need to
Caption: make things better
Caption: the other thing is
Caption: make it clear that
Caption: your company is a space where
Caption: neurodiversity is accepted
Caption: um the one final point i make on
Caption: disclosure and
Caption: i kind of hate that i have to point this
Caption: out but don't speculate about what
Caption: conditions people have
Caption: because
Caption: it's it puts can put some in a position
Caption: where if you ask them hey i think you
Caption: have this condition
Caption: then either they have to say if they
Caption: have the condition they have to
Caption: effectively lie to you or disclose when
Caption: they want to but if they don't it can be
Caption: really insulting
Caption: at the end of the day
Caption: your speculation probably won't be very
Caption: accurate because you're not a
Caption: psychologist diagnosis is a serious
Caption: thing and requires real knowledge
Caption: let's talk about the environment
Caption: when we design environments for
Caption: neurodiverse people or adjust
Caption: environments for narrative as people
Caption: there are two things we're trying to
Caption: achieve
Caption: the first is we're trying to reduce
Caption: sensory overwhelm because people with
Caption: neurodiversity get overwhelmed by their
Caption: senses because it's processed
Caption: differently
Caption: the other thing we're trying to do is
Caption: reduce unnecessary socializing so we're
Caption: all social creatures we enjoy having a
Caption: bit of a chat for banter and
Caption: neurodiverse people as well
Caption: but every new diverse person has like a
Caption: threshold for that like i don't like to
Caption: banter as much as my team typically does
Caption: but and just giving the opportunity for
Caption: them to sort of take a step back from
Caption: that
Caption: so let's talk about things in details
Caption: first of all have areas with lower light
Caption: uh this is a big one for beer and
Caption: university they find light often very
Caption: overwhelming
Caption: and if you could have air in your office
Caption: which is just a little bit darker maybe
Caption: the lights are dimmed or some lights are
Caption: turned off and it can make a big
Caption: difference also avoid fluorescent
Caption: lighting for the area because some
Caption: people really even some neurodiverse
Caption: people really don't like influence and
Caption: lighting
Caption: they have areas in co-working spaces
Caption: which are slightly separated and or
Caption: blocked off so if a big open plan area
Caption: you can make a big difference i'll give
Caption: you an example of this when i did my
Caption: internship we had two
Caption: rows of tables and one at the end and
Caption: this was repeated across the floor
Caption: i always went to the table at the end
Caption: because i felt that first of all if i
Caption: was
Caption: on that table in the corridor i felt
Caption: like i was always staring at someone and
Caption: someone was always watching me work the
Caption: second reason is and i swear this isn't
Caption: why i chose the table at the end it had
Caption: two giant monitors
Caption: now i don't need that many monitors i'm
Caption: a software developer not whatever needs
Caption: two giant monitors
Caption: but
Caption: what it basically did is meant that
Caption: there was a slight block so i didn't
Caption: have to sort of be in on the banter
Caption: someone talked to me they just have to
Caption: move their chest slightly to the right
Caption: and this really helped me focus
Caption: have quieter spaces so areas where
Caption: there's just less talking or less other
Caption: noise
Caption: allow the use of headphones or earmuffs
Caption: so for example
Caption: one of the things that pretty much
Caption: necessary for me to cope is when i'm not
Caption: talking to someone i usually have my
Caption: headphones on not just when i'm coding
Caption: but also when i walk around the office
Caption: uh if i see someone i want to talk to
Caption: i'll just pop them off have a chat and
Caption: then put back on i even bring them to
Caption: meetings with me so
Caption: obviously i don't wear them in the
Caption: meetings that would be kind of
Caption: counter-intuitive though i'm sure
Caption: there's some meetings where we all wish
Caption: we could wear a pair of headphones and
Caption: just nod along
Caption: but basically once the meeting was over
Caption: and everyone's dispersed i just pop them
Caption: back on and continue with my flow
Caption: uh be flexible around work areas for all
Caption: the environmental reasons i've discussed
Caption: so far sometimes people who are nervous
Caption: really just like one area of the
Caption: building
Caption: so example from my brother's company
Caption: someone with autism got promoted
Caption: congratulations he's like oh awesome
Caption: thanks
Caption: here's your bigger office so he's like
Caption: no thank you i like this small one
Caption: another example is i know someone with
Caption: adhd and she
Caption: uh her team moved from to a different
Caption: building and she didn't like it as much
Caption: so they worked out condition a
Caption: situation where she could work part-time
Caption: with old building and part-time in the
Caption: new
Caption: is this fight is bui a lot easier to
Caption: make
Caption: um even on teams of high collaborations
Caption: one day we can make a big difference so
Caption: i used to work at home one day a week
Caption: and
Caption: which is good because i like that day
Caption: where i can work my optimum environment
Caption: at home and have a bit of a break but
Caption: also seeing my team enough to really
Caption: build those professional relationships
Caption: and provide opportunities to discuss
Caption: environmental issues one little thing
Caption: you can do
Caption: is
Caption: you can just once or twice a quarter uh
Caption: post on your team
Caption: teams uh or other shout out hey is there
Caption: anything about the environment you don't
Caption: like
Caption: uh if your team is anything like mine
Caption: you probably get some memes like i know
Caption: what i don't like about the team greg
Caption: can get rid of him
Caption: but someone might have
Caption: surreal feedback that will improve their
Caption: life not necessarily even a new diverse
Caption: person maybe there's a plant that's
Caption: really smelly maybe their office uh
Caption: their desk hasn't been a standing desk
Caption: for a while between the motor broke
Caption: and finally overall
Caption: try to reduce sensory and socializing
Caption: reduction options for people with
Caption: neurodiversity
Caption: let's talk a little bit about job design
Caption: first of all
Caption: uh give the option provide written or
Caption: verbal instructions i don't know how
Caption: something i do personally i don't know
Caption: how many other people can do this is
Caption: whenever i give instructions to a team
Caption: i type them up while i'm talking so you
Caption: get the benefit of both
Caption: uh give more detailed instructions if
Caption: desired something that might manage to
Caption: be dub on very quickly
Caption: is that i need about 30 to 50 more
Caption: detail instructions this isn't this line
Caption: of code this line code and this lag code
Caption: it's just
Caption: here's where you get this from or hear
Caption: who you talk to
Caption: uh adjust job sign where possible to
Caption: remove tasks they struggle with
Caption: if you know someone in university really
Caption: struggles with a task especially as a
Caption: task that other people just find
Caption: perfectly normal
Caption: uh you can read it does help a lot to
Caption: reassign those tasks
Caption: and what you can do is sometimes people
Caption: with neurodiversity are really good at
Caption: tasks that other people struggle with so
Caption: you can balance that out a really
Caption: trivial example is is in my home i have
Caption: one there's liquid soap dispensers
Caption: i really hate the feeling of conjured
Caption: soap
Caption: so i get my dad to refill it
Caption: and in return i vacuum the whole house i
Caption: think that's a pretty good deal
Caption: um but just recruitment or have separate
Caption: equipment for neurodiverse people so
Caption: often we
Caption: we all kind of know that interviews
Caption: aren't the best way to assess someone
Caption: just because you interview well doesn't
Caption: mean that you're good at your job
Caption: that's why a lot of companies have moved
Caption: to stuff like you know sit down and
Caption: write this algorithm for me or
Caption: whiteboard out solution or what have you
Caption: um you can make more adjustments in
Caption: traditional recruitment methods through
Caption: people who are neurodiversity for
Caption: example if someone with autism
Caption: uh maybe give them 10 minutes alone with
Caption: a whiteboard
Caption: or ideally have separate recruitment
Caption: processes tailored for neurodiverse
Caption: people a lot of companies especially
Caption: have programs for people with autism who
Caption: typically don't interview well
Caption: include neurodiversity in
Caption: diversity and human resources policies
Caption: and discussions if it's hopefully
Caption: already included that's not already uh
Caption: shoot an email to whoever's in charge of
Caption: that
Caption: if it's hr you might earn yourself some
Caption: brownie points
Caption: normally the reason for it isn't
Caption: anything malicious normally it's just
Caption: oversight
Caption: but all this is a lot of stuff
Caption: there's actually a simple activity i
Caption: really like
Caption: let's say you meet with your team on a
Caption: regular basis daily or weekly
Caption: and it's always in the same room or a
Caption: similar room and it's in one of these
Caption: very fancy offices that we all tend to
Caption: work in these days
Caption: often these officers have the ability to
Caption: dim the lights
Caption: and what you can do is you just take two
Caption: minutes one meeting to say hey
Caption: i noticed the lights are difficult uh
Caption: here's what looks at this level this
Caption: level this level does anyone have a
Caption: preference
Caption: and a lot of people say no i don't
Caption: really have a preference but it might
Caption: mean a lot to someone
Caption: and then if it means a lot to someone
Caption: just reduce the lightning and start
Caption: lighting at the side very meeting
Caption: and you just did your first step to
Caption: being an ally of narrator's people
Caption: and all this is important because things
Caption: are changing
Caption: up until
Caption: now there's a real culture around fear
Caption: of care diverse people oh what happens
Caption: if my employer finds out that i have
Caption: insert condition
Caption: uh will they think less of me what will
Caption: people think i hope my condition doesn't
Caption: you know cause me to lose my job
Caption: or caused me to not get a promotion
Caption: but this is changing
Caption: this is changing to a culture of pride
Caption: because people with neurodiverse
Caption: conditions are slowly understanding that
Caption: it's just something about themselves it
Caption: comes with strengths and weaknesses it's
Caption: something to be proud of i think it's
Caption: proud to be a woman it's proud to be of
Caption: certain ethnicity or it's proud to be
Caption: lgbt
Caption: and
Caption: more they're looking for companies that
Caption: are accepting of that and value that
Caption: and when it comes to acceptance it tends
Caption: to go up over time you have your
Caption: outliers like bank west who all the way
Caption: back in 2016 gave a fantastic
Caption: presentation at test west
Caption: about how they created a internship
Caption: opportunity for some with autism in the
Caption: software testing field
Caption: bankwest always kind of being ahead of
Caption: the curve in these sort of things
Caption: then fast forward to current year 2021
Caption: you have companies like ey microsoft
Caption: c-a-r-c-a-i
Caption: woodside and deloitte
Caption: most of them offer autism specific
Caption: opportunities
Caption: and
Caption: they're all neurodiverse friendly
Caption: and there's a good reason for that as i
Caption: said neurodiverse people people are kind
Caption: of specialists they have minds of every
Caption: kind and that can unlock a lot of
Caption: innovation possibilities
Caption: a lot of the innovators of the past have
Caption: been very diverse so let's run through
Caption: some examples
Caption: you have dr vernon smith
Caption: diagnosed with autism
Caption: nobel prize winner of india economics
Caption: he did groundbreaking research in
Caption: experimental economics don't ask me that
Caption: one what that means i don't know but
Caption: it's good enough to give a nobel prize
Caption: you have
Caption: cotton
Caption: diagnosed with autism
Caption: inventor of bittorrent an innovative
Caption: peer-to-peer networking protocol and
Caption: trust me it can be used for things other
Caption: than piracy
Caption: one of the interesting ways it's used is
Caption: when a large multiplier gamers need to
Caption: distribute to thousands or millions of
Caption: users quickly on launch often they use
Caption: peer-to-peer networking to make that
Caption: possible
Caption: and there's a lot of other niche uh
Caption: situations where people in networking is
Caption: extremely useful
Caption: if richard branson
Caption: diagnosed with adhd and dyslexia
Caption: successful founder of the virgin group
Caption: they do airlines they have space company
Caption: their bikes mobiles radio and they once
Caption: do soda such a really interesting story
Caption: well worth for google
Caption: and most impressively i'm pretty sure
Caption: this is uncontested he was the first
Caption: billionaire in space
Caption: stephen fry
Caption: diagnosed with autism
Caption: beloved british actor he ui beef and
Caption: vendetta he charges his guide to the
Caption: galaxy he's a real powerhouse of the
Caption: actor but loved by
Caption: pretty much anyone who knows of him
Caption: and he was the voice actor of
Caption: the video game little big plant which i
Caption: already mentioned because it's just a
Caption: delight to listen to
Caption: going back quite a number of years now
Caption: we have michael faraday
Caption: michael faraday is an interesting one
Caption: because dyslexia is diagnosed based on
Caption: your writing style lesson is a specific
Caption: dyslexic style and historians went
Caption: through and looked at his personal
Caption: journals and manuscripts and
Caption: historically diagnosed him with dyslexia
Caption: it's one of the rare cases where we can
Caption: do that
Caption: now his main discoveries include the
Caption: principles underlying electromagnetic
Caption: induction
Caption: diameter
Caption: diamagneticism
Caption: and electro analysis now i especially
Caption: don't know what that means but what i do
Caption: know is it was really big
Caption: in the electrical engineering field
Caption: like anyone who knows a lot about
Caption: electrical engineering history would
Caption: know who michael faraday is that's why
Caption: they call it the fahrenheit k cage has
Caption: anyone's heard of that
Caption: in the world of entertainment we have
Caption: billy ellis
Caption: diagnosed with tourette's syndrome
Caption: famous for musician famous musician and
Caption: creator of songs like bad guy and bury a
Caption: friend
Caption: she won many grammys and billboard
Caption: awards and if you haven't heard of her
Caption: it's because she's popular with the
Caption: youth
Caption: now many in the program here today do
Caption: still consider themselves youths but
Caption: that in case you didn't hear of her
Caption: and then
Caption: it's the iceberg
Caption: and this iceberg is especially deep
Caption: because knowledge and understanding and
Caption: the ability to diagnose nervous
Caption: conditions have only really come out in
Caption: the last
Caption: couple decades so all the great minds
Caption: historically
Caption: have been speculated by psychologists
Caption: and historians to be
Caption: neurodiverse and this is informed
Caption: speculation give everyone from isaac
Caption: newton to nicola tesla steve jobs
Caption: and i don't include them as examples
Caption: because
Caption: i'm iffy on speculation
Caption: but something to keep in mind
Caption: and certainly what these companies keep
Caption: in mind
Caption: because time and time again study after
Caption: study has proven in time itself that
Caption: companies that are diverse
Caption: get ahead because they have a diverse
Caption: set of minds and diverse their
Caption: backgrounds to work on things
Caption: so when these new graduates come forward
Caption: and they're prideful about their
Caption: conditions because at university people
Caption: talk about their conditions openly
Caption: it was a shock to me when i entered the
Caption: workplace and people were like oh yeah i
Caption: don't tell anyone
Caption: people are
Caption: increasingly prideful in their
Caption: conditions and they're looking for
Caption: accepting workplaces they'll accept them
Caption: for who they are and the strengths that
Caption: we can see that come from that and when
Caption: these extremely talented people are
Caption: looking for work
Caption: where do you want your company to be on
Caption: this distribution
Caption: so far
Caption: i've only talked about how nervous
Caption: people can benefit you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: and that's important
Caption: we all do this for a living
Caption: this is how we make money while most of
Caption: us anyway
Caption: but the fact of the matter is you can
Caption: change someone's life
Caption: which is a bit of action which hasn't
Caption: been changed in the workplace
Caption: you can change someone from feeling
Caption: overwhelmed and horrible at the end of
Caption: the day because things are too bright
Caption: too noisy now they have to do jobs they
Caption: really struggle with
Caption: someone going home at the end of the day
Caption: and feeling amazing like we want
Caption: everyone to feel
Caption: or even more important than that
Caption: you can make someone
Caption: go home at the end of the day
Caption: so you can give someone the opportunity
Caption: to work to begin with
Caption: because some people cannot work
Caption: unless they're given unless they're
Caption: given a more university-friendly
Caption: environment
Caption: typically in a presentation like this
Caption: you would see the statistics on universe
Caption: people in employment
Caption: and
Caption: i'm not including them
Caption: the reason for this is
Caption: when i was first getting diagnosed i
Caption: went to a presentation like that
Caption: and that was so upsetting i almost left
Caption: the room
Caption: they are pretty blue
Caption: people who have narratives conditions
Caption: struggle with both acquiring and keeping
Caption: work
Caption: and finding especially finding
Caption: meaningful work
Caption: and now i suppose it's a good time to
Caption: transition to talk about my own journey
Caption: all through out my life and especially
Caption: after school
Caption: i had this problem where you expect in
Caption: life things will get better over time
Caption: you'll get a job you'll get promoted
Caption: you'll um
Caption: get a girlfriend you'll buy a house all
Caption: those big life milestones
Caption: but for me i found that i wasn't making
Caption: any progress
Caption: i felt constantly stressed overwhelmed
Caption: upset
Caption: i didn't know why
Caption: eventually mental health issues filled
Caption: that gap for me
Caption: i felt really terrible about myself and
Caption: that eventually led to me
Caption: um
Caption: being a pharmacologist but thankfully
Caption: she picked up one
Caption: very quickly that i had autism
Caption: and gap gave me the tools to both
Caption: understand myself
Caption: and use the understanding to start
Caption: building things to get better
Caption: so far on this talk i haven't really
Caption: discussed much about neurology
Caption: and there's a good reason for that i'm
Caption: not a neurologist
Caption: however there is a really good way of
Caption: explaining autism that i found and i've
Caption: given this explanation of neurology in
Caption: front of neurologists
Caption: and they didn't yell at me
Caption: in fact one was like
Caption: yeah that's about right
Caption: so
Caption: let's do it
Caption: broadly speaking the brain can be
Caption: separated into three layers you have the
Caption: reptile layer that's very fast very dumb
Caption: uh that's good for stuff like um
Caption: the flight of flight mechanism or you
Caption: hear rust in the bushes and you're like
Caption: girl what was that is that a tiger
Caption: uh in my backyard
Caption: you have the intuition layer which is
Caption: kind of slow kind of smart and sort of
Caption: like when you have a general feeling
Caption: about something like i feel this
Caption: conversation is going well or
Caption: i
Caption: feel
Caption: scared
Caption: about this situation not actually their
Caption: feelings but yourself interviews
Caption: and then above that you have the
Caption: cognitive layer which by comparison to
Caption: other ones is extremely slow but very
Caption: smart
Caption: this is when you actually stop and think
Caption: through something think through the code
Caption: you're working on or you think through a
Caption: situation that you're in
Caption: people with autism
Caption: lack that intuition layer and the
Caption: cognitive layer has to take over
Caption: basically all these responsibilities
Caption: and to illustrate this difference
Caption: i'll give an example when someone comes
Caption: and gives you a hug
Caption: what happens in your brain is on the
Caption: reptile like they go
Caption: that's enormous look at his giant arms
Caption: he's going to attack me
Caption: and start to send out warning signs now
Caption: the intuition layer before the reptiles
Caption: signals can even let leave the brain
Caption: goes bad that's a hug i like hugs
Caption: and then a million years later the
Caption: cognition brain catches up and goes oh
Caption: that's nice i like hugs oh strange this
Caption: person doesn't usually hug me
Caption: in songs of autism's brain the red type
Caption: brain goes
Caption: and then they either freeze up or
Caption: sometimes back away
Caption: and then ages later the cognitive brain
Caption: catches up
Caption: and usually what happens is they think
Caption: like ugh i hate hums my sisters are
Caption: having me
Caption: or
Caption: let me stop a hug again
Caption: and this change
Caption: manifests in a couple of interesting
Caption: ways people autism tend to be smarter
Caption: that's because their cognitive brain is
Caption: constantly being worked out
Caption: but people with autism
Caption: also tend to get overwhelmed honestly
Caption: because
Caption: every single process approach every
Caption: single change that presented to them
Caption: they have to process
Caption: on the conversation they have to stop
Caption: and think through it
Caption: this is why people don't like systems
Caption: because once you systematize something
Caption: you don't have to think about it you
Caption: just follow the system
Caption: um this is also white people with autism
Caption: so i i find that when there's a small
Caption: change i actually have to stop and think
Caption: about sometimes
Caption: like for example imagine you think you
Caption: know what someone is you go over there
Caption: looking for them and they're not there
Caption: i once uh turned the corner and we'll
Caption: just
Caption: stared at the person's desk for a good
Caption: minute until the slightly unfriendly
Caption: person next to him said what
Caption: i was like
Caption: so that would be an awkward situation
Caption: so let's talk about what happened after
Caption: my diagnosis
Caption: so i struggled with socializing and
Caption: productivity
Caption: i passed most of my bachelor's degree
Caption: which is four productive hours a week
Caption: and i got pretty good grades
Caption: on average i'd sometimes go weeks at a
Caption: time without having any productive hours
Caption: and then do like 12 hours and complete a
Caption: project in a day
Caption: over time
Caption: i got so much support from the
Caption: university system and from my
Caption: psychologist and from my doctor
Caption: and most importantly from a mentor
Caption: and
Caption: this led to progress at a time where i
Caption: went from 4 hours to 8 hours to 16 hours
Caption: to 20 hours
Caption: eventually to 30 hours
Caption: and this is where i felt i was ready to
Caption: test my progress so
Caption: i applied for woodside on
Caption: a friend's recommendation
Caption: and i offered a job and i died i
Caption: disclosed that autism immediately
Caption: and they were so supportive i found that
Caption: supportive team hr came in before i even
Caption: arrived at the business
Caption: and
Caption: gave the team a whole bunch of
Caption: information
Caption: and when things were struggling the team
Caption: was there for support
Caption: and because of all this
Caption: i know someone who can work
Caption: because i do conserve myself as someone
Caption: with a disability in the way it might be
Caption: due to the way my orgasm presents itself
Caption: i went from someone who five years ago
Caption: in 2016 when i was diagnosed could not
Caption: have a job and thanks to the allyship
Caption: and support of people from university to
Caption: the workplace
Caption: i am now someone who can hold down a
Caption: full-time job and i know i have a lot of
Caption: value to give
Caption: and that's why i'm giving this
Caption: presentation because i believe it's an
Caption: important message
Caption: and it's why i'm so thankful to our
Caption: sponsors
Caption: if it wasn't for the generous
Caption: sponsorship of the people on the screen
Caption: this event would not be able to happen
Caption: and we won't be able to share important
Caption: messages that we've been able to share
Caption: today
Caption: both important technical things which
Caption: makes us all better at our jobs
Caption: and important other messages that make
Caption: our companies better make people's lives
Caption: better
Caption: and makes our products better
Caption: and i'd also like to thank the
Caption: incredible volunteers who've
Caption: generously volunteered so much of their
Caption: time
Caption: and squeezed every last drop of value
Caption: out of those generous
Caption: sponsors
Caption: sponsors money
Caption: what i'd like to end on is
Caption: you
Caption: can't decide
Caption: who
Caption: innovation comes from
Caption: you can't just say you
Caption: come up with a market changing
Caption: innovation or you uh we have this
Caption: multi-million dollar problem that's
Caption: extremely complex just solve that real
Caption: quick please
Caption: innovation requires the right mind for
Caption: the right task or right minds for the
Caption: task if you don't have a diverse set of
Caption: minds in your organization
Caption: you're going to miss out on innovation
Caption: because the organizations that do will
Caption: leave you in the dust
Caption: thank you so much for your time today